hey what's up guys my name is achana
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we talked about uuids and
introduced them into the engine check
out that video if you haven't already
and today now that we've got uuids let's
talk about how we can actually hit play
and set off our scene runtime because so
far what we've been doing is simulating
an existing scene whereas we know that
in reality what we probably want to do
is basically load up the scene that
we've been editing in like a runtime
state so what does that even mean and
how does that work okay well let's let's
jump into what we've got so far so we've
got this um
uh basic setup that we established i
think last episode and maybe during the
box 2d kind of physics episodes this is
what we have if we hit play
it'll jump to whatever the game camera
kind of is and then obviously we will
see this kind of physics simulation
taking place right that's all good but
as soon as we hit stop obviously we
don't reset anything um you know it
would be ideal for you to reset
everything right and that's probably
another thing we should do is um
not display the gizmo or at least
display the gizmo in the correct
location when we hit play using this
camera instead but anyway the point
being that you can see that we obviously
don't reset anything when we hit stop
everything just remains exactly as it
was because all we're doing when we hit
play is rendering from a different point
of view and then running the physics
simulation which allows us to modify our
transform component data that's all that
is that is actually happening here which
is not good for a number of
reasons or on a number of levels really
because the thing is if you think about
the issue at the moment yes it might be
true that all we really need to do
is just like remember the transforms of
these objects or of any physics object
and then just reset it when we hit stop
right but that's not really sustainable
and it's also not going to scale well
because
at the end of the day
there are a lot of things that can
happen during a scene right i mean if
you if you think about involving a
script runtime i mean just think of a
game made in like unity or something
like that right we could have a script
which spawns the entire level
procedurally does all of this stuff
right sets up prefabs you know spawns
them into the world runs physics
simulations runs other code that
generates like assets like textures even
you know the amount of work that we can
do once a game starts
is i mean it's honestly infinitely it's
infinitely large right like we could do
literally anything especially once once
we have like a script runtime so what we
kind of want to do with this scene is
not necessarily reset it what we want to
do is actually create an entirely new
scene based on whatever this editor
scene is right so that we have physics
2d this is our current scene right when
i hit play i want to be able to
basically load this scene in kind of a
runtime fashion i guess you know
establish the box 2d world and anything
else that needs to be kind of present
for a real scene
but then like
you know run that scene instead
and then when i hit stop i can just
delete that scene you know release it
and then basically change the scene that
is at play here in the editor to be that
original editor scene that we were
editing
right so in summary i mean again long
story short if you actually think about
what needs to happen here
we just need to copy whatever scene is
currently being displayed here we just
need to copy this scene into a new scene
which we can call runtime scene and then
basically switch the editor to now be
kind of to use that runtime scene as the
context for literally everything
right but then when we hit stop switch
that contacts back to whatever the scene
was that we were editing
so
how we're going to do that one other
thing i want to quickly point out before
we go there someone i think pointed out
a bug where if you are playing and then
you try and load a scene it will just
crash so
we should probably fix that
before we get into it into this but
other than that that's kind of the plan
for today just to make that kind of
copying behavior work
so if we go over here so okay so open
scene
i guess we just won't let
scenes be opened if we're running or
rather we'll stop the scene first
because we still want to load the scene
probably so if if we do open scene if
the current uh state scene state equals
let's just say if it doesn't equal edit
right then we're just going to run stop
scene or scene stop
on scene
stop
right so that should fix that bug
let's take a look at that make sure that
works all right scenes physics 2d i'll
hit play and i'll drag it in again
okay so you can see it just stops it
which is kind of what you would expect
okay great um i mean we could bring up a
dialogue being like hey are you sure
you're doing this maybe your
hand just had a spasm and you
accidentally dragged that in i don't
know but we'll leave it like this for
now so that's that that's that bug fixed
okay so copying scenes and all of this
architecture how is this going to work
so of course this was kind of discussed
and i did implement this in the last
live stream right so i'll kind of be
using the code that's already actually
present in the in the dev branch not to
be confused with hazel dev it's not
hazeldub this is just the dev branch on
the github
uh repository right that's there'll be a
link in description below so you can
always you can obviously kind of see the
code that's already been written as part
of the live streams that happen on
twitch or tv slash the churno but anyway
getting into it so
the thing that really needs to happen
here is we obviously need to uh
basically have some kind of runtime
version of this scene now we have a
scene called active scene and this is
fine but what i'm going to do is i'm
like i'll leave active scene like it is
but then i'm going to explicitly set up
two different scenes an edison scene and
a runtime scene right now you don't
technically need to retain three kind of
scene refs or three pointers here
because i mean at the end of the day
there's really only two scenes there's
the editor scene and the one that we're
currently running i'm just i've written
it like this with three actual scenes
just so that it's a little bit more
verbose and will make hopefully more
sense so in the beginning what happens
is well not in the beginning but when we
open a scene
what we want to do
is uh basically instead of setting the
active scene to be this new scene that
we're loading over here we want to
specifically
if the decentralization worked out i
want to set the editor scene to be this
new scene right
that's kind of what's going on here
instead and then we can do all of this
resize stuff but then what i'll do is
kind of when that's all done and maybe
based on some other states i'm going to
actually set this to be the editor scene
so the active scene and the editor scene
are actually kind of equal i mean
they're two different references here
that they're two different shared
pointers but obviously the object itself
is the same so these are
this is what happens when we deserialize
the scene we load it into the editor
scene and then we set that to be
to be active
now
when we hit play though
we don't want to just do one runtime
start what i want to do here is i
actually want to set the runtime scene
to be um some kind of like
i don't know maybe we'll make a function
called copy
uh well the way this works in hazel dev
it's actually called copy2 and then you
can give it a target scene to copy into
but i'm actually just going to make a
scene
a scene copy function and it's going to
return a new scene
for us right
and then so we'll create that runtime
scene and then what we can do is well we
can call onruntime start and then we can
set the active scene to be the runtime
scene right and then all we have to do
over here is make sure that we obviously
call runtime stop over here and again
whether or not you do this on the active
scene or on the runtime saying they
should be equal so it's not really a big
deal but the point is we're going to
change the active scene to the editor
scene now by doing so
right um i mean by doing so the runtime
scene here obviously like the um
if we keep track of all of these
reference counts in our mind the editor
scene is always going to be parked here
right and i'm beginning to think that
maybe this is even kind of over
complicating it so
well
i i but i do think that the distinction
between the names is good i don't know
because and you're about to see why i'm
saying this in a minute but
uh
what we're doing here is the editor
scene will permanently be parked in the
editor scene shared pointer right so
that will always kind of exist in memory
but here if we do the same thing with
the runtime scene that's obviously not
something i want to do because once a
runtime scene gets stopped we can
basically delete it right and the
simplest way to do that is probably to
just set runtime scene equal to null
pointer
so what this will do
is uh reassign runtime scene to be
something else right which will mean
that the reference count will be
decremented and it doesn't matter really
where you do this like we could do
runtime scene on runtime stop right
runtime scene equals null pointer then
activecalls editors in but the point is
as soon as nothing obviously has that
run time scene anymore then the
reference count will fall will fall to
zero and we will completely delete that
object from memory so the idea is when
we hit stop obviously since nothing else
is holding a reference to the runtime
scene it will in fact be destroyed uh
yeah but it's important i guess not to
um
and you can probably tell here that
there's no need for this runtime scene
right because active scene is runtime
scene and it only exists for that
lifetime but i've just written it this
way so that it's um a little bit more
kind of aware but again i'm i'm doubting
myself as i'm recording this episode
because i don't know maybe just makes
sense to have an active scene and an
editor scene and then obviously what you
would do is just basically well you
wouldn't need this you just said active
scene equals to scene copy active scene
or editor scene
right so we make a new scene out of that
maybe i'll do it that way you guys can
let me know what you think in the
comments below didn't really plan this
to be honest but we could make the
active scene copy the editor scene
and that's obviously a reassigning
active scene to this new scene that
we've made right assuming that
everything goes okay which it should um
and then we just do active scene stop
active scene null pointer or rather we
don't even have to do that we just set
active scene to edit scene and since
active scene is the only thing that ever
held onto this kind of new scene that
we've made it will then get destroyed so
it's a little bit cleaner this way but
it might be a little bit harder to
understand
because active c anyway whatever so the
thing with active scene is that
everything else kind of works with this
design right like you can see that
basically like you know we still have
active scene on update active scene on
render uh wherever that happens or on
update sorry does the rendering active
scene on viewport resize you know what i
mean like we've just changed the active
scene to be this new scene so everything
else will work we don't need to do any
kind of like if it's the runtime update
the runtime scene um no it's all kind of
going to be inside active scene and of
course that would have worked if i had
the runtime scene pointer as well it
doesn't matter anyway
so it's in copy editor scene this is
kind of the meat of it right so how are
we going to write this function well the
hardest part of copying a scene is
copying the end registry right because
it doesn't really have a good copy
function or clone function i think it
used to but it's been removed and i
think they're planning to add it back
because this isn't really traditionally
like it's not really traditionally a
behavior that the entity component
system should really support i mean it
definitely should because
there's so many reasons too right but in
terms of the scope of an actual ecs
you don't really copy an ecs usually
right it's kind of the meta programming
that you do around the ecs that would
require you to copy it within the ecs
itself there's no reason to your
registry kind of just exists with all
these entities you don't really copy it
right
but for this purpose we obviously need
to copy all of the entities all of the
components that are inside here and
remember it's really just the registry
is really just component data and then
we have entities which are identifiers
into certain kind of components right so
that we're aware that like our camera
has a camera component and a transform
component with these values so the
components are really what we are trying
to copy but we also need to somehow
retain the entities so that we know
which components belong to which entity
right because that's equally as
important as just having the physical
component data
there but anyway so what we'll do is
um i guess i'll just maybe i'll do it up
here static ref scene copy
right and then this will take in just
another scene that we are going to copy
um i don't know maybe i should do this
at the bottom i like putting static
stuff at the bottom but if it's to do
with construction i generally put it
here
so let's create this okay cool get rid
of all of this extra fluff
so ultimately like the point here
obviously is just to create one of these
scenes so i'll call this new scene
right now this will just be create ref
uh scene
now if we look at what a scene actually
is i mean it's the registry but then
it's also just a viewport with height
and a null pointer kind of box2d world
which really is only needed for the
runtime scene so if you bought width and
height i don't know if we need to copy
that the reason i'm saying that is
because if we look at editor layout i
think it just sets the viewport like
every frame maybe
so set viewport size edit the camera
active scene on viewport resize
well no actually it so it gets the
viewport size from the frame buffer from
the frame buffer specification okay i i
think what it probably should do here
because yeah because for we don't have a
scene renderer yet that's right
yeah okay i guess we probably should do
that just because obviously i don't
think the frame buffer is going to
change and then therefore we won't have
the correct values in this new scene so
what we'll do actually is as the first
kind of step over here
is we'll just copy those values right so
a new scene um and by the way i could
use a copy constructor i'm aware i just
wanted to kind of make this return a ref
specifically and be a little bit more
kind of explicit as to like you want to
copy this
um so it's not like an accidental copy
so we'll do new uh
scene viewport width equals a viewport
yeah height is obviously what i wanted
um and then we'll do height and sorry m
is um this is static right so we need
the other scene as well
so other is like the source that's like
the destination i could kind of rename
the source and dest but
i guess we'll keep it like this to be
deliberately hard right
okay so the way this is gonna work is
there's basically two stages to this we
need to copy the entity identifiers
right which means we need to create
entities in this new scene but then we
also need to patch up their components
and copy the components and it would be
it would be good to try and kind of do
this
obviously as efficiently as possible
so what i what i'm actually going to do
and the other really important thing
right is that we can't simply just
create entities
we actually need to make sure that we
use this new function we wrote last time
to retain the identifiers of the
entities because obviously those ids are
going to be used for a lot of things and
they need to match right if another
entity is like a child of some other
entity which i know we don't support yet
but we will right then obviously it
needs to know what its parent is if it
like some entity references another
entity again it's probably going to do
that internally via the uuid so
therefore it needs to actually match
right you can't just create this whole
new scene with completely different
identifiers because then nothing will
like the relation between objects and
between entities will be lost so we need
to specifically do this right so the way
we're going to do that is basically
we're going to just look into every
entity that we have and the best way i
think to do that is um basically to just
establish this kind of okay well the
first thing i might do is pull out the
registry so we'll say um
we'll call this like source scene
registry and this will just be sourcing
being other so other m registry
right this is just a little alias just
to make it a bit easier and this will be
our kind of destination scene registry
which is going to be this new scene
and then out of there what i'm going to
do is actually i'll call this id view
we're just going to basically ask the
source scene registry where we're
copying from to set up a view with id
component right because what this is
going to do is basically i mean
ultimately this is going to give us
every single entity that we have right
because obviously every single entity is
going to have an id component and then
we're going to loop through this all of
these id components that we have and
just create entities and we can do that
by basically well there's a few ways we
could do that i mean ultimately at the
end of the day we're just trying to call
um new scene create entity with uuid but
clearly we need two things a uuid and a
name for that entity so that's what
we're gonna pull out here
um the
uuid uh will just be
e dot
um
well
i guess we'll just use we won't make it
in like a hazel entity sourcing registry
get
um id components
dot id
and sorry we need the
the actual entity and then we'll also
get the const
order i guess name
which will be the tag component
right so we have a con string here so
uuid
and name
right
so what we've done here
um is we basically created
all of these new entities so every for
every entity that we had in the old
scene we've created a new entity in this
new scene right now
they are going to have the same id the
same uid however within and within
entity right
within that library
the id that they have is going to be
different most likely right so what that
means is that again like that's fine
because we don't trust that anyway
that's just uses an indexing for a data
structure right uuid is what we actually
use to identify entities and that's the
way it should be
so
the last thing that's going to be a
problem here which we might revisit
later because we'll naturally see this
this pop up
is we need some way to actually know
which entities
you know which of these entities
that we've created here corresponds to
which uuid
now we could ask it to please give us
all the entities without with id
components let's iterate through them
and let's try and find you know
an entity with this id
right
why because we obviously have to give it
components now that's the next step so
we'll talk about how we can do that with
a little bit less kind of finding by
just using a map basically but the next
step is to copy components um now the
two components we don't need to copy
right is
id component and a tag component
why oh well um yeah id and tag why
because this is what we've we've already
copied them right so create entity with
a uid obviously adds an id component
with that id and a tag component with
that name right it has the transform
component however we still have to copy
the values from that transform component
so we'll have to do that here in a
minute but the point is that id and tag
should be intact and now we just need to
copy everything so how do we do that
well i'm going to write this in a very
simple easy to understand way that we
will probably change a bit later because
i just want to introduce it kind of
softly
but what we're going to do is we're
going to write a function called copy
component and we're going to basically
call it for every single component right
it's going to be a templated function
just trying to be a little bit relaxed
here on the templates and stuff
so template type name
t i'll call this component actually
and then this is going to be called copy
component
um so how do we copy a component well
a few things has to have has to happen
here right so we need to um basically
look it up from the source registry see
what it is and then copy it into the
destination registry for a particular
entity and this is again where things
get a little bit complicated because we
can easily pass in these registries
right so it's just going to be ant
registry so we'll do this um i guess
i'll put the destination first kind of
like uh
mam copy and stuff
so we'll have the destination registry
the source registry um but the problem
is that whilst uh you know we can copy
the components if they exist um and
we'll talk about that in a minute we
obviously need a little bit more
information than just this is a
component right because a component
has you know so like the component is
its data but then we also need to kind
of link that component to an entity
because an entity has to own a component
but the problem is if we're arbitrarily
copying components here well yeah we
have a bunch of entities in destination
we have a bunch of entities in source
but as far as ant is concerned their ids
don't match right uuid is what we need
to use to match them up
right so how do we know
which component belongs to which entity
and this is where it gets a little bit
tricky so ultimately though let's start
setting this up we just want to look we
just want to establish a view right of
the source registry for whatever
component thanks for that correction for
whatever component we're trying to copy
so in other words in this case it's
transform component i'm passing in the
destination scene
registry and the source scene registry
so i've got this i've got this transform
component that's what component is i'm
establishing a view of of the transform
components which again should be laid
out all together kind of in memory right
and if that is the case then obviously
it's nice to iterate over all of them it
should be quite efficient so then we'll
go ahead and we'll just do
auto e
uh in view right but again like what
needs to happen here is i need some way
now to
because i know the source registry
entity is e right but i don't know where
it should go into the destination for
which entity should i be copying this
transform component into right that's
what i don't know but that's again where
that uuid comes in so if i just do
a source dot get right it's going to be
id component
for e right then what i've done is i
actually know what the uuid should be
right that is the uuid
of
this source entity which can tran which
contains a transform component but what
i need to do is somehow figure out where
inside and that id component is for that
new entity this is getting very
complicated and it's hard to explain it
really makes sense i probably should
just draw something but i think you guys
are hopefully getting the point maybe
i'm over explaining this but my point is
that again we've established the uuid of
the source entity from the source
registry that we're copying from we just
need to know where to put it into the
destination and we know that obviously
the id is going to be the same but how
do we communicate that to end right
because ant is the thing that is
actually going to store this like we
need the ant id right which is ants
entity this is what we need so that we
can add a component to it
but we don't have that right so this is
where um we're going to introduce a map
so that we can actually map these id
components into that because the other
option would be to basically um set up a
view right an id view or something into
the destination registry so we could do
like a destination view id component
right and then obviously we could
iterate through that so that would be
like d e destination entity id view and
then see if d e
um you know get uh sorry um what would
it be uh id idview.getidcomponent
uh
d e right dot id equals
this source id
right and if that's the case then d e
is where we add it so we can do d e
you know in place
um d should be an n t right
no sorry it's from the register
obviously so it'll be like dst dot in
place
um whatever we're copying
you know four
there's a nightmare for
the
this entity right and that's how we
would basically and we'd pass this along
into the copy constructor
like
um so well we need to actually get the
component as well right so we'd need to
retrieve the component as well like
whatever this is so that would be like
auto
component equals
source dot get
component
e
why does it keep capitalizing it come on
go away i've never actually done this
before so if i try to type in like
transform
component
which it doesn't even know
then i think it should be able to maybe
like look it doesn't even know do i have
to do hazel
transform component
does that work
thanks bro maybe that will help with
intellisense but anyway
and then you pass in component
so hopefully this makes sense right this
would work and this is fine but we have
this like extra level of like for you
know we get a nested forward we have to
iterate through all the entities in our
scene just to find it like that's really
really annoying considering we already
have the both the uuid and the entity
kind of thing here so what i'm going to
do instead
right of doing it this way is i'm going
to basically set up something
um and this can be
i don't really care what this is it
could be unordered it could be ordered
it doesn't really matter i guess we'll
put it into an unordered map um because
we haven't i don't think we've
implemented the lesson operator anyway
and we have the hash operator so we'll
do uid and then end entity which is
really just like a uint right but the
the point is what we have now is an ant
map and we're just going to make it like
on the stack over here
i'm like we're not going to set it up as
a member or anything like that doesn't
need to be and then what we'll do is
into copy component we'll pass in this
end map right
and then i'll grab the end map like so
it's going to be a const in fact the
source can be const as well the source
registry
um and we'll call this antmap
right and what so what does this do it
avoids this entire search right because
instead of this what we do is like we
have the id right it's over here let me
just bring this out and try and be as
clear as i can
um
[Music]
right
we have the source
id right which is the same as the
destination id so now all i have to do
is basically just do end map dot at
right
uh uid and that gives me the actual
entity
[Music]
like identifier so ant id
that's it
right
that's it
so this one kind of line avoids
this entire kind of search here which is
obviously going to be very good for us
so uh and that will only just grow when
you have you're basically reducing like
this kind of linear search um with uh
you know just like a constant
time lookup right so
order n i guess versus order one so
anyway the point is uh this is a better
way of doing things and that's why we've
done it that way
i had a pretty long day today by the way
so if i'm a bit slow i apologize
um so
yeah that that's basically it right and
then we can actually get to the meat of
this which is copying the component so
we know which entity is kind of the
destination receiving entity this is the
entity this is the destination entity id
i'll be really clear about that
right so the destination end id so now
what we can do is into the destination
registry
i can
now here's what i want to do i want to
do in place or replace why because it
already has a transform component so i
want to replace it with this new
transform component right whereas for a
lot of components it won't be replacing
it'll just be adding so for a camera
component that obviously wouldn't exist
so i'm actually creating it so in place
of replace is a good function for this
so what i'm going to do is do in place
or replace and then we're going to do
whatever component it is that we're
working on right which is in our little
example as a transform component
and then we're going to actually put in
this component right oh and of course we
need the entity which is destination cid
right and again what this will do is it
forwards all the arguments into the
actual uh you know constructor and of
course every one of our components has a
copy constructor here it is so that's
what we're doing here we're just using
that copy constructor to basically copy
it now
you know we could probably make this a
little bit
um
cleaner but i'll leave it like this
because i think it makes more sense and
then we basically have to do this for
every component that we have now
as i said i'm going to do this the kind
of easier way um what we probably should
do is establish some kind of component
registry so like a component type
registry right where we just have like
all of the components that are
components and then we can like kind of
i don't know constexpr statically
compile time iterate through that and
then call copic into component write a
template which expands that into every
single
uh component that we have right if
someone wants to write that by the way
then maybe like open a github issue on
the repository and just write like an
implementation of that i'd be happy to
review it and accept it in the next
episode uh
i'm doing it this way for now because
first of all i think it's just going to
be a little bit more clear without just
complicating the code
so that people understand like the basic
premise of how it works and also because
i'm i'm not going to pretend i'm a
template expert it's probably going to
take me a little bit of time to actually
write something like that so uh but if
you want to then that would be great
because we will we will do that
eventually like i'll probably switch to
that in any way uh okay so let's take a
look at all the components we have so
transform sprite renderer uh we don't
have that many so i'm not gonna bother
like um
you know
kind of
going through all of them and that's why
this is also okay i think that actually
might be it do we really only have five
what do i have oh yeah native script
which i think is right on the camera
i'm doing it in the same order as it
appears over here all right so that's it
um
now we've copied everything and of
course i think that should be it so
we've copied the entities we've created
new entities
right so create let me just uh
just reorganize this so create
entities in new scene
and then of course uh copy the
components right which is the actual
data that makes up the entity so
that looks good to me i don't hopefully
i haven't
introduced any bugs here um but yeah
that's actually pretty much it that's
all there is to making this new scene we
should now have a scene that is
identical to our other scene apart from
maybe some different um like entity ids
like ant ids very hard to distinguish
between between the word and c and then
the library entity
because they're called the same thing
but anyway you get the point all right
great so back over here um what does
this mean uh well
i actually think it will just work
possibly
so let's it'll be scary let's try and um
compile this around this and we'll see
what happens
okay so here is our physics 2d test
scene let's hit play okay we get a crash
that's okay um yeah one thing i should
have done is probably in a certain oh
well actually that's a bit silly so this
maps are obviously empty so we need to
actually add the stuff into the map i
can't believe i forgot that so um
basically again once we have the
destination entity which we've created
over here right because what it does is
it returns an entity
i'll call this new entity
right a new entity
is going to contain
an id
which i think if we just use it as a s
so how do we get the handle out from it
well actually it it has an implicit cast
so we can basically we should be able to
just do and map
the uuid is uid equals new entity
just like that and we can obviously be a
little bit more explicit about this if
we want but again the type is just that
so it should be fine
right so there we go we um
we are putting that in and of course you
know you could cut that whole thing out
if you wanted to
and just do that right but i'll be a
little bit more explicit as usual okay
great so now and again you know what we
could do is it's very it's very unlikely
if this to ever really happen but since
we are using at and not find we could
put in a little assert to make sure that
um nmap find uh was called uuid
doesn't equal and map and
just to like you know
be like this shouldn't happen hopefully
it makes more sense kind of in the code
i guess assets by the way they're not
just i think they're not just for like
actual debugging and validation during
runtime like like they usually are used
for they also make more sense on code
right because you're telling the
programmer here that this should never
happen pretty
obvious right so they kind of they
actually document the code pretty well
as well
all right so um hit play we got our play
hit stop we've got our stop right so
what we have achieved here
is again we can hit play we can do
whatever we want with our scene
um you know and obviously what's going
to happen
is when we hit stop it's going to reset
pretty amazing stuff now the last thing
i want to do today actually which i
almost forgot about is i just want to be
able to duplicate entities right so we
have um the ability now to copy
components right and because we have the
ability to copy components we should
also be able to kind of uh introduce
this kind of uh duplicate function
which actually i mean copy component is
a little bit different because this uses
like an ant map and it's clearly made
for scenes but what i want to do is uh
just write a function here called
duplicate entity
um entity entity
right and this is just going to
duplicate it so what do we need to do
for duplicating an entity well let's
create a new entity now obviously in
this case we actually do want to do
create entity without uuid right we
wanted to generate a new id for it
because obviously we're creating a new
entity so the name is going to be uh
well i guess we'll use the same name so
we can do entity get component or is
there just a get tag no
well let's add that that's kind of nice
so we have get uuid so i'm also going to
do a const std string
get name
right
and then it's just going to return
tag component
tag we should probably call them names
because tags can be used for other
things but
uh that way we can just do get name and
everything looks good and then finally
what i want to do is i actually want to
create a function called copy component
if exists right so this is going to be
similar to this it's just a bit
different because we like this is within
the same registry right so it's
obviously way more kind of simple but
what we do need to know is the source
entity
and the destination entity
right so and i'll call it copy component
if exists because obviously if it
doesn't exist then we won't copy it and
you'll see how this is going to work
it's very very very simple if the source
entity has the component
every time
then destination
uh
dots destination add now the problem
here is that again we want a bit of like
that in place or replace thing so what
i'll do is i'll actually copy this and
i'll call it uh i guess what should i
call it probably like add or replace
component something like that
um
add or replace component
so we don't need to set this
um because it's fine if it already has
it
uh and then we'll just do in place or
replace that's really the only
difference and then i guess we'll do
this garbage as well but that's it right
and then this again for things like
transform component it will just
overwrite it but then for things that
don't um
have it
right because i'm talking about the
destination just because when we create
the destination obviously it's going to
already have a transform component and
that kind of stuff but we'll do um add a
replace component component
visual studio
and then um
uh you know we'll have to do like source
i guess get
just going to copy this because
otherwise it's going to capitalize it
and i think that's it right so if the
source has the component we add it into
the destination entity and that's it
again this all happens within one
registry so clearly it's kind of
different than
what we had uh
before now all of the components right
we'll do it the same way again once we
have
um
the uh
kind of component registry we'll just
iterate over it but what we'll do is
let's do
so this is going to be copper components
this and then we'll call it
i don't like this isn't okay that's okay
though so destination is new entity
source is entity
not the best um
naming as usual but that's okay
all right we'll go ahead and uh go
through all of these as quickly as we
can
and that's it right so we now should be
able to duplicate entities so if we go
back over here
um we i'm going to make obviously a way
for us to be able to do this through the
editor i'm just going to make a control
d
so we have uh on saying stop on we'll
just make a function called on
duplicate and see we should have like
some kind of command thing maybe
soon but this is like really simple this
is just gonna be like if
um
[Music]
i guess if m scene hierarchy panel
get selected entity if that's even like
if we've even got anything selected then
we'll do em edit the scene now uh this i
guess should only happen
if we're in edit mode right so if if
scene state doesn't equal edit we'll
just return
but otherwise
oops just close the file um but
otherwise we'll just do editor scene
duplicate
entity and then it'll just be this
so i guess i'll do
i don't know should we write
code like this probably not
i don't know if that works on all
compilers these days
we'll just do this so um yeah and then
we'll just basically just duplicate it
so how do we how do we call this well
ctrl d as i mentioned so if we go over
here
um we'll just add another one of these
commands maybe i don't know those are
also commands
uh scene commands maybe i don't know uh
d and then obviously if we hit
just control
i don't know if i like this whole on for
this but whatever
f5
so yeah so now we should be able to
duplicate entities which is actually
going to be oh errors everywhere never
mind
so in place or a place uh didn't seem to
work out because i have parentheses in
the wrong place
all right loading in our physics scene
so this is actually this duplicate into
you might be like why am i adding this
because it makes it so much easier to
make little levels right so all i have
to do now hopefully this even worked is
if i hit control d
ah didn't work this is just fun
so create entity with
something to do with the tag
error characters okay let's debug this
so what error that was just an error
entity.getname okay so that didn't oh
well
so what if it doesn't have a name but it
has to have a name right because if it
doesn't have a name
then it has
it has the name entity if this if it was
created with an empty name so definitely
should have a tag
right
so
i wonder why
um
wait did i i definitely had something
selected yeah i did
get name
get component attack and part another
tag const string
okay tag component tag
uh that should be okay let's try and
debug this a little bit we'll see what
the entity handle is if it lets us
so let's go back to duplicate nc
oh it's got an empty handle of zero
that's weird so we didn't have anything
selected
handle zero
then why did that pass that
oh cause zero isn't null so i guess so
is that fine then i guess it is fine
zero is a valid id that's right
i keep thinking zero is not valid but
this this clearly didn't work this is
very strange i still don't know why this
is happening the other thing i can think
of
is
um because what happened is so we
retrieved the name here
but then we call create entity with id
which adds
another tag component
so it's
possible that the location in memory has
changed
for the original tag
but that like
i
don't know
so what
i guess what we could try is that's very
annoying though isn't it
we could try give it like a name that's
you know been copied but
it's kind of annoying so basically if we
go back here
we do antsy
name like this
let's see if that
also um doesn't work okay so one thing
i'm noticing by the way just as i open
this
is that the scene hierarchies is blank
what
is it
what
that's suspicious already
um
why is this scene hierarchy panel blank
oh
because it gets the context gets set to
active scene which is not
which is nothing okay so let's do this
we'll go to open scene
so if it had no context then it couldn't
have returned a correctly so that nc
never existed i think was the problem
because it never had
it never had a real scene but no but
hang on when we hit open though we set
it to be active scene oh but this is
before we do that
all right so editor we'll change this to
the editor scene and then the other
thing i want to do is when we actually
hit play we should set it to not be the
editor scene right so on scene um on
scene play
we'll set the context to be this runtime
scene which is active scene and then
we'll do the same thing on stop
right so that way uh you know if we are
spawning entities while our game is
running we'll be able to see them pop up
in the scene hierarchy panel so i
suspect that we probably like that makes
sense now oh well that just crashed
i was gonna say that makes sense now um
but i i don't think we need the let's
see why that crashed but i don't think
we need the yeah the the string and um
copying the string and stuff like that
anymore but what's going on here on i'm
going render doesn't work
uh yeah because context is null so what
happens do we not
can this just not deal with
no scene
that's weird
well whatever so basically obviously we
only want to do this if we have a
context though
the way i'm i'm shocked that this worked
before that's very weird
so if there's no context then we'll just
do a blank panel
yeah i don't know what was going on
there
that's weird i guess when you create it
you're forced to give it a context
immediately
oh but where's the properties panel
whoops
so the properties panel happens here so
and that's only if we've got selection
contacts so actually that doesn't need
to
it's just this panel if there's nothing
to display then there's nothing to
display and again it will have if it's
an empty scene it'll just have an empty
context like it won't be empty empty
meaning it's null it'll just be a blank
scene
um yeah this whole engine is uh okay
that must have just been me yeah because
end is here
oh begin yeah whoops
we still want to draw the actual panel
just not the contents inside it
if you like for the scene hierarchy
panel
lots of little stuff here happening but
um okay so let's try and let that scene
okay we actually have that stuff now so
now if i hit control d yeah that seems
to have worked
let's go back and fix our code so that
it's not
um doing this
so that should be okay right we should
be able to
just get the reference of it because we
don't want to copy the string because it
should still remain where it is i guess
and then if i hit ctrl d oh it crashed
this is um super interesting what i want
to do is let's just grab this again
let's put a breakpoint in and i want to
see what's actually happening here
because it looks like um because i want
to see what happens when we hit ctrl d
let's see what our name is
so our name is floor that looks like
it's correct we're on duplicate entity
but then once we add this
tag components
aha our name is changed error rating
characters of string right so i guess
what's happened is
it has in fact been moved in memory
and now the reference is invalid right
so
uh
yeah that's a bit unfortunate i guess
um
but that's the way it is so
we will have to actually preserve this
somehow you could also make it so this
doesn't like return a const reference
right because i guess it is kind of
dodgy this will always give you a
reference if you don't copy it so you
could always do that but i guess for
name like if you wanted to
you could change it to
return by value like that but again me
personally i think that if you know what
you're doing it's better to just have it
returned by reference so that if in fact
it wasn't a scenario in which we're
actually playing with the registry
um and potentially moving things then it
would actually uh you know it would
still remain a reference but this way if
you actually want to copy it that's very
bright
but this way if you actually want to
copy it
then you can of course you know
write code like this which will in fact
copy it because you're making a copy of
it
so now i guess this should work yeah
that was unexpected i think i'm pretty
sure i wrote the code with the const
reference and with everything in the
live stream
and it was totally fine so it might have
just been a case of the registry didn't
need to resize yeah weird i don't know
or maybe i'm just missing something now
no clue
but anyway let's get rid of all of this
stuff
control d yep seems to have worked
anyway so as i was saying the benefit of
control d and all of that stuff is that
obviously now we can uh easily set up
this scene to be way more interesting
right
so if i um come over here
you know maybe let's set this up here
we'll duplicate this you can see how we
can start to create a pretty interesting
world
right of this thing moving down
pretty easily
right and if we hit play
then we can see that's rolling now we
can be extra cool with this right what i
can do is i can actually make my camera
we could also give the camera a rigid
body
and a box collider and make it
dynamic and now
that's strange um we probably uh should
uh the problem is it'll it'll start
bumping into stuff itself so maybe i
wonder why the size is zero by default
though
shouldn't that not be zero
shouldn't be like 0.5
why is it zero
i don't know box colliders had
um a size of zero
yeah it should have a size of 0.5
uh is it because it's duplicating it
from somewhere no i just added the
component
hmm that's very strange
oh i think i know what this is
i think so let me just hit like control
s here
um
oh control s doesn't work rip
oh my goodness me
okay whatever i didn't lose that much
work but ctrl s
should fix it right now but we're out of
time anyway um let me quickly see i
think i saw a comment about this
yeah we're just displaying the offset
twice so this is actually size
whoops not in russian um so yeah so i
think i was um
[Music]
yeah it was like the actual values are
fine it's just it was being displayed
incorrectly i can't believe that
stupid control s
anyway all right so
take three um let's do something
exciting now
um
let's move this around
i hate not having ctrl s we should do it
very soon
okay and if we hit play then that's
great but we can't see anything so let's
go to the camera let's add a box
collider
except we can make it quite small
um
0.1.1 or something
and then we'll add a rigid but it
doesn't matter where it is like the fact
that the camera is far away because of
course it's only 2d physics so we'll
make it dynamic and now you can see we
kind of
kind of follow it right kind of
now one thing we could also do is
actually fix the rotation that'll
probably make it a bit easier but yeah
you can see how we kind of more or less
follow this but the camera actually has
its own physics associated with it which
is pretty cool
and we can be really cool and add like
some restitution as well so that we're a
little bit bouncy and you can see how
fun that is right so you can see that we
can kind of already start making some
kind of game here and obviously the
great thing is when we hit reset
everything resets and everything's fine
let's maybe make this this dynamic
that'll be interesting
now everything kind of falls that's
that's it it's kind of boring anyway um
yeah so i think what i'm gonna do right
now actually just because you know what
i'm i'm just gonna do it episodes long
anyway let's add ctrl s
so back to editor layer
um what we'll do is we'll do save scene
as i'll just make a save scene right
that's just going to save the current
scene now for that to happen we need we
need to know what the current scene is
right so active scene i don't know if
this has a file path i don't think it
does because it doesn't know anything
about files so what we'll do is we'll um
just make an std file system path
current uh scene path or we'll just say
edit to scene path right
when we open
scene right if it works out and
everything's fine then this path right
if we deserialize we'll just set the
editor scene path to be the path
right and what this means is that when
we want to save the scene so save scene
let's go ahead and make that happen
when we want to save the scene
um we'll just use that so if the if this
is like a real path because we might not
even have something open
and it also might not be i guess it
might not have been made yet
so is there a way we can yes check if
it's not empty so if it's not empty
uh then we'll just do this basically
right so um well again this is a bit
uh okay we might have to change this a
bit but
yeah ultimately this is what we're
trying to do and this unfortunately
takes a string so for now we won't
change it
but that's really all that needs to
happen if it's if the path isn't empty
we do that right now if we hit new scene
um this is a big one you probably want
to make sure that you actually like
reset this right to something else i
don't know if you can just set it to
empty um i guess it doesn't like that sd
file system path can i just not set a
path i guess i can do that
uh because we obviously don't want
otherwise we'll hit ctrl s and we'll
overwrite our old scene with this new
scene that is empty and that's a great
way to lose work
so
make sure you don't do that make sure
you kind of keep up to date with that um
and then obviously every time we open a
scene when we do save scene as we also
want to change that right so we'll do
save scene as and then we'll do
um
what is it editor scene path equals file
path
so that's what we've saved it into so we
basically need to update the path and we
need to kind of keep track of that
that's important so ctrl s if it's um
shift so let's just do if control
and then if
shift we'll do save scene as
else
um well if it's nothing
we'll just do save same
okay and that's pretty much it now the
only thing that i don't like about this
is that we kind of have this kind of
code duplication here which can make it
annoying i mean i guess here we don't
need to update it but what you could do
is call save scene from here but this is
specifically not safe scene maybe we
should make a serialized scene function
probably let's maybe do that so we'll
have we have safe scene but let's make a
serialized
scene um and serialize scene is going to
basically take in a scene to serialize
and then a path so this will be like the
ultra kind of
um
correct way of doing this so what we'll
do is basically all i think it needs to
do is this so we basically grab the
scene
and then we serialize it to this path
and i think that's it doesn't ask any
questions doesn't care you just do it
right and so that's good because
obviously we can call that and it's a
little bit more clear as to what we're
actually doing this this takes in the
file path
um
[Music]
and then here we do edit a scene path
okay cool that looks pretty good to me
so let's go ahead and hit f5 test that
out i think that's the only two things
that save anyway so i think we should be
good and i made the control i'm actually
implementing control s i think um if
it's empty won't do anything but
actually it should bring up um
it should probably bring up
the save as thing right so if we move
well let's just duplicate this basically
so
i'll duplicate this
put it somewhere else
uh hit control s and then
i don't know something else load it back
there you go okay so it has in fact
serialized it and then i guess the final
thing i'll do to tidy this up a little
bit is
um
yeah we can just say i guess
else
save scene as right you could also have
make that happen inside that switch kind
of on event function that's also fine
this is programming lots of ways to do
the same thing we could talk for hours
about the the benefits but yeah the the
good thing is that if i start a new
scene and then hit ctrl s it's going to
bring up that save as dialog box which
is exactly what we want anyway thank you
guys for watching this video i hope you
enjoyed it if you did please don't
forget to hit the like button you can
show your support as well as get access
to hazel 3d the big version of hazel
i'll probably keep calling it everything
even though we've agreed that this game
engine series is hazel 2d and that is
normal hazel but anyway
patreon.com best way to help support the
series get access to all of the lovely
source code and of course you'll be
supporting development of the series as
i mentioned about 500 times a huge thank
you to everyone who does do that that is
in fact why i am able to do this so
thank you i think we're pretty much
caught up with like the live streams now
uh the well the live stream that i did
last week so tomorrow which is uh
thursday i will be live streaming on
twitter tv slash the channel as i do
every thursday working on the next
episode whatever that may be of this and
then we'll probably have it come out
like maybe on maybe even tomorrow night
we'll see but anyway thank you guys for
watching i'll see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you